alors Cyril Mathieu je suis très surpris
de la part de Béatrice qui est une fille
intelligente sympa ça part bien quelle
est aussi peu d'autodérision et surtout
si elle n'a pas d'autodérision j'ai une
seule question à lui poser qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait dans cette émission parce
que elle a quand même ça pas du échapper
que dans cette émission moi je suis le
mec qui a fait ouaf wouah foufouf est
capable incapable beaucoup de mental
pour être animateur lui elle c'est les
Black tout le temps lui l'alcoolique lui
il est cocu
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes physique d'Elton
[Rires]
des analyses politiques mais ce que je
voulais dire par là c'est que on sait
tous à peu près qu'on a la carrière
qu'on a en vrai on va être très honnête
si on serait pas forcément là on serait
là voilà mais rien n'est très grave moi
je veux dire un truc moi moi moi je vais
vous dire un truc aujourd'hui je le dis
quoi moi je ne pourrais pas être à votre
place parce que c'est un autre talent
c'est un autre talent donc je n'ai pas
et je l'ai souvent dit c'est beaucoup
plus dur pour moi d'être chroniqueur
animateur je pense vraiment je vous jure
que c'est vrai parce que vous devez
amener du contenu à chaque fois moi j'en
ai rien à [ __ ] je me dis n'importe
quoi non mais c'est vrai non mais
vraiment donc je vous le dis ne croyez
pas je crois c'est une énorme talent
d'être un très bon chroniqueur et je dis
juste la Béatrice que je crois que si
les gens nous aiment bien ils nous
regardent le soir c'est parce qu'on se
prend pas tellement au sérieux rien
n'est très très grave on a la vie qu'on
a la qu'on a parfois on dit d'énormes
conneries parfois on dit une chose
plutôt intelligente et voilà il y a rien
de très grave je pense
et voilà et je dis juste alors je dis
deux choses à Béatrice la première c'est
que si je l'ai blessé je m'en excuse
parce qu'une blague qui blesse c'est une
mauvaise blague exactement je dis aussi
à Béatrice et là vraiment je me permets
de parler pour toi bébé Béatrice si tu
n'as c'est à moi
Béatrice si tu n'as aucune autodérision
et là vraiment je te le dis pour toi
sinon l'année va être très longue arrête
TPMP parce que c'est la base de cette
émission j'ai fini
un pied devant l'autre comme disait
Jean-Pierre Mader Béatrice
[Applaudissements]
on va appeler Béatrice qui est derrière
le rideau c'est impossible
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît Béatrice
Béatrice
Mathieu c'est dire ça apparemment dans
un film en tout cas on peut aller très
belle elle est très belle et puis
vraiment tu peux aller rien de mauvais
non si tu es drôle tout passera
Béatrice ma chérie tu as entendu ce qu'a
dit Mathieu
tu as vu qu'il a fait un pas vers toi
etc c'était de la vanne c'était de
l'autodérision c'est vrai je suis pas
d'accord avec ça il faut dire la vérité
parce qu'en fait le principe de ce jeu
c'est il y a que la vérité qui compte
n'est-ce pas ouais mais fais gaffe quand
même
[Applaudissements]
tu vois voilà moi j'ai pas envie de
devoir virer tout le monde tu vois non
mais j'ai pas envie de faire un plan de
relance dans l'émission
les sentiments global
Béatrice déjà est-ce que tu as quelque
chose de négatif à dire sur moi
alors c'est bon tu peux y aller
[Applaudissements]
le grand jeu de Mathieu c'est de laisser
penser que les vannes sont pour
l'antenne pour faire rire la galerie et
que tout ça n'est qu'un qu'un grand jeu
et qu'une grande façade en fait quand on
voit les les trucs de Sacha et le base
les images de Sacha le les masques
tombent et on voit qu'en fait Mathieu ne
joue pas la méchanceté pour ça il
faudrait avoir du talent pour être
heureux
prochain en fait il y a une différence
même pendant les pubs on rigole ensemble
on aime bien vanille moi je veux bien
tout mais dans depuis le début de
l'émission il disait pas bonjour Il est
désagréable il met des non il dit
bonjour à personne
il me dit bonjour il me demande de
l'oseille pour dire que je suis un
connard bien tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
on connaît la personne vous vous
connaissez mais les gens sur les réseaux
sociaux et crois encore ils ont encore
l'illusion
ne croyez plus en cette illusion ce que
vous voyez et la vérité voilà c'est tout
maintenant on peut on peut passer à
autre chose alors
alors on vous y croyez oui
hier pardonne lui là est-ce que je peux
dire quelque chose bien sûr lundi
j'étais chez moi tranquille je venais de
finir les devoirs avec mon fils qui a 7
ans ma petite fille à 4 ans elle est pas
de devoir et j'allume la télévision et
pile au moment où Mathieu commence sa
grande interprétation
j'étais avec mon fils même mon fils a
compris qu'il comprenait pas il sait pas
ce que c'est Wikipédia etc mon fils a
compris que
tu voulais m'humilier si tu veux et il
comprenait que c'était à la télévision
est-ce que Mathieu est-ce que Mathieu
est-ce que tu veux bien emmener son fils
et jouer club ce weekend
et la Grande Récré également on est
obligé de citer j'ai mes deux magasins
de weekend Béa ma chérie
Mathieu
Béatrice oui
l'important Béatrice c'est que tu n'es
pas dit de mal de moi
[Rires]
maintenant si moi je peux donner mon
avis Mathieu c'est Mathieu et c'est vrai
que Mathieu voilà on rigole avec lui
c'est comme ça qu'on l'aime voilà moi
Mathieu si Mathieu était lisse Matthieu
serait pas là Mathieu on est content de
l'avoir et on est content qu'il soit là
et c'est vrai qu'on aime pour ça moi
quand je vais voilà je vais même donc
même dans l'émission C'est voilà c'est
ces aspérités sa singularité
on aime et c'est vrai que pendant les
pubs aussi même quand on voilà on n'est
pas tendres avec c'est plutôt que c'est
de la vanne mais c'est vrai que regardez
Benjamin voilà vous pouvez tout à
l'heure il a quand même pris 20 ans 2
ans
mais c'est vrai voilà à cause de Mathieu
mais pourtant il s'adore et c'est vrai
que voilà ils sont tout à fait voilà
Guillaume regarder l'état dans lequel il
est
non c'est vrai voilà on voit que les
gens ont mangé
Mathieu et Béatrice Patrice que tu es
prête à faire un pas vers Mathieu
Béatrice
je suis toujours gentille toujours
souriante toujours sympa avec lui donc
voilà c'est c'est des attaques gratuites
jour après jour après jour
c'est pas une émission
sur l'Ukraine non pardon ce qu'ils
veulent c'est venir ici se détendre avec
nous déconner j'en prends 53 des blagues
ici ça me vexe jamais rien ne me vexe
pas ta méchanceté
comme ça je suis désolé mais enfin
normalement si tu avais très bien tout
le monde le sait très bien tout le monde
le sait très bien tous les gens qui sont
méchant
est-ce que tu es prête est-ce que tu es
prête à ouvrir le rideau
moi je suis prête à ouvrir le rythme
le rideau
tu peux me dire norbécile
et insupportable peut-être oh là là mais
il y a rien à arrêter aussi ou pas je
suis moi-même et tu es toi-même aussi et
je te le redis franchement mais vraiment
j'espère avoir et un petit peu
d'autodérision le
c'est pas moi ici je crois vraiment dans
cette situation le problème c'est mort
53 minutes parce qu'on a fait une vanne
sur ton nom parce que
si tu veux fais 10 minutes sur toutes
les émissions que j'ai foiré tu peux y
aller à Wavre machin le bac
[Applaudissements]
entre nous on est en direct
alors voilà
on va pas faire 4 heures dessus donc
alors demain
non mais je vois pas David des autres
les chéris
c'est juste pas possible donc si vous
voulez
le rideau donc Béatrice peut-être elle
reviendra demain
et toi vous allez la nuit va porter
conseil Béatrice tout cas merci ma
chérie pour l'instant tu n'es pas prête
à ouvrir le rideau
voilà donc Béatrice reviendra demain
voilà on fera un jour sur deux non non
non on sera ensemble demain
on fera ensemble demain voilà de toute
façon je pense que tout ce côté ne peut
plus blairer et tu t'emportes très bien
ah voilà et tu vas aller exactement se
passe très bien allez merci
le Maroc